Prior to being diagnosed with squabble cell carcinone, my tonsils, I was having post nasal drip, which was causing sleep apnea. I bought a Navage machine, which I've used in daily, and I think these Navage machines I don't have one, but I think they're great.
Helps keep my side. This is clear. However, sometimes during the day and always overnight, I continue to manufacture mucus that comes down my throat, cause me to cough.
But muscle tested for allergy bacteria, viruses, as it's worse than before, could this be from detoxing from using my protocol?
I could be, I don't think it's from detoxing them. Lots of practitioners want to use that as an excuse for symptoms.
Really, most of the time, there's no real rationale for that. I think it's because whether you are taking a lot of immune stimulation, and you're using the right to help kill your cancer, you're stimulating your immune response against that cancer.
You are going to produce more mucus. You are going to produce, because mucus is a function of histamine production, which is a pre immune function stimulation, you're producing a histamine and other immune pre immune cytokines to stimulate an immune system attack on something.
So that's why if you have an allergy, you're going to produce a lot of histamine, because an allergy stimulates your body, thinks that you're having an immune attack on something, and it's stimulating that pre immune response.
So I think you're just, you know, you don't want to stop that, you know, when we're killing cancer, you're using a bunch of immune stimulation to help attack your cancer. So that's not something we want to stop.
Now, I would agree that you, you know, you're using I've been drinking slippery LT and sage and honey, but I want to eliminate the source of the mucus. I think the source of the mucus is that you're purposely trying to stimulate your immune system. So I don't know that you want to certainly don't want to stop that.
But certainly taking things that will decrease cytokine formation, which would be like curcumin, green TX tract, things that we talked about over and over that will help decrease inflammatory cytokines.
So the curcumin, the EGCG from green tree, green TX tract, the corsetin, and stiggy nettle, things like that, things like that are really you're going to be your goal to things.